so you're the guy who started the wall
street bets subreddit that like broke
wall street and the internet just a
couple of months ago
uh yeah yep that that uh that would be
me you're responsible for that
no well i mean i started it i didn't per
se
so first of all let me just ask you this
what's up with all the i mean
all the trolls on youtube and everywhere
else saying like
this guy's a fraud this guy didn't start
wall street bets do your homework
[ __ ] this guy what is all that [ __ ]
about i
actually i i'm yet to see somebody that
says i didn't start wall street bets
that that's the one attack that i
haven't seen i've seen everything else
though i mean
it does surprise me that i haven't um
gotten that one look it's it's
uh it's there's a story behind one
there's a great story behind that i was
removed as a moderator so i started it
in 2012
and i was uh in charge of that subreddit
until april of last year
and uh some things went down between
me and some other moderators and uh and
i got removed right
uh that particulars to that story
are good and they're also been sold to a
movie studio so i can't get into those
details but i give you all sorts of
insights
uh as far as what went down right based
off of some public
information that you'd have to kind of
scrap together but the accusation that
was leveled against me was that i sold
out the subreddit that i was trying to
profit from it
right which is you know it's a silly
argument in it of itself but but i did
two things that uh that triggered these
accusations the first one was
i wrote a book and i started selling it
on on
amazon and i was promoting it on
facebook and on twitter just like you
would any other product and
uh and obviously i also promoted it on
reddit i did it
ama on that subreddit and i posted a
link on the subreddit
um but that's but saying that i wrote a
book to sell out the subreddit is a bit
of a
sell it's it's a bit of a a shallow
argument because
for starters i wrote a book right if i
wanted to to really just kind of make a
quick buck
writing a book is not the way to get
rich um i'd be selling t-shirts like the
current moderators that
that are uh doing just that and have
their link on the side of the subreddit
uh that's the first part the second of
all you know the book itself wasn't even
about the subreddit itself it's more
about the stock market and things
the second thing that i was accused of
was to create a scam
uh competitive day trading competition
so i had this this vision
uh last year that since people are
starting to treat this thing like a
video game meaning the stock
market uh and video games as a whole are
just a really up and rising
uh market and i decided to kind of merge
those two ideas together where we'd have
kind of a competition people would i'd
rented out the biggest esports
uh stating sorry esports stadium in the
us and i was going to have
12 contestants go on there and actually
trade real stocks with real money on the
stock market for a couple days
and uh give a huge price to whoever won
plus whatever he gets to make from from
the trading competition
unfortunately coronavirus showed up and
it shut down the world it shut down the
olympics all the sports all the
traveling all that so of course my
my idea went down and the idea and so i
was accused of trying to scam
people from their money there right like
they said that i'm gonna take their
money for for entering the contest or
whatever um
but but that's a silly argument that
doesn't really hold up
it doesn't hold up because i have a lot
more to gain by
actually doing this than i would from
making a quick box stealing you know a
couple hundred thousand dollars and then
going to jail
uh and and so that argument is going to
fall apart because of course
i had the whole thing tied up and now
i'm putting it back together again
coronavirus is under control
uh this thing has only grown the
attention is only increased the number
of people that are in the stock market's
only bigger
and so now i have people in casinos that
are competing to try and have this event
at their place and so
sooner than later i'm actually going to
pull this thing off and so
both of those arguments are going to
kind of fall between the cracks
oh that's cool man so you're still
trying to make that happen um
what was i going to say uh you sold the
rights
to the story of the breakup between you
and the guys who are currently getting
control of it too
can you tell me which studio you sold to
yeah it was rat pack
um that was it's public yep it's a big
studio they did
hundreds of movies that are really big
so did they reach out to you
like when this whole thing like sort of
blew up on the internet
yeah you know it was actually kind of
interesting uh i started getting it
contacted by all sorts of uh movie
people you know
producers and writers and directors and
and
studios and this was far outside my
my understanding the hollywood business
is completely
foreign to me and uh and so yeah so i
started kind of lobbing the calls and
everyone was super helpful that
one guy even uh wanted to try and
uh secure me so bad he bought a flight
to mexico and he was like hey i'm gonna
be there my flight lands tomorrow
morning you know i'm gonna take you out
for some drinks
and we're gonna sign this thing right
and i was like dude you should have
asked me because i'm going to be out of
town this week
so he came down to mexico and i don't
know what he did um oh my god
but yeah no i so i ended up talking to a
lot of people a lot of big names that
you'll probably recognize
worked on a lot of really prominent
movies a lot of people that ended up
uh signing deals of their own with movie
studios
and uh and kind of hearing out their
pitch and learning about how it works
and and
the the the most promising offer was
this one from rat pack so i just went
ahead and took it
now do those guys talk to the other guys
on the other side of the uh
on the guys who are running the reddit
thread now it is a
deep rabbit hole uh
there's so many people that are running
the reddit thread now and in fact
the people that were running the reddit
thread then were different than the ones
that are writing it today and by then i
mean january or february yeah because
there continues to be drama
some of it related to the original
problem and some of it not but
essentially i was at the top and then
there was uh
and the way that reddit works is you
create a subreddit you're the top
moderator
and you basically have full control you
can add and remove every
moderator below you have full
permissions and as you go adding
moderators you can give them permissions
and even if you give them full rights so
they can do whatever they want
they can't remove anyone that's above
them as a moderator so if there's ever a
disagreement whoever is further up the
food chain
is is ultimately the one that's in
command and so the group of people that
were left there before
there was some more infighting and uh
and those guys
the best of my understanding they did
speak to movie studios
uh and i don't know if anything happened
with that i think it also had part
partly to do with the fact that they too
ended up getting removed
uh by now this third group of moderators
so it's it's kind of the wild west there
so if you were on the top of the food
chain how did you end up getting removed
those rates belong to rat pack no they
i mean they did a very good job
like that there was it was a complicated
situation and
uh they effectively managed to overthrow
me they got reddit involved and reddit
decided to
to pull the plug and that's how they did
it wow
and i did it twice they did it again
with the other guys too
no [ __ ] way
that's pretty bonkers man it's such a
[ __ ] wild story and you were like
everywhere in the media you're getting
interviewed by cuomo he's all geeked up
on there talking to you like asking you
all these crazy questions
yeah well it's crazy crazy about tv is
like you can't really see them
uh and and so you know you try to kind
of make a joke or crack whatever you
can't
you don't get that corporal language so
so i mean it's a little joke with cuomo
uh because he just finished roasting uh
vlad attentive the ceo of robin hood for
you know stopping the trades or whatever
so he was really mean to him so i was
like hey
i'm new to this can you be nice to me
and it was just radio silence and i
couldn't see his facial expression and
he just kind of kept going with his
questions i'm like i guess not
that [ __ ] was so insane he looked like a
[ __ ]
robot his eyes were like about to bust
out of his skull
the way